when you've got it right you see your
protein moving and changing shape and
your school rushes up your own player
name rushes up through the ranks and
yeah your underlings start it's like
being a scientist when you get a paper
published that 10% of euphoria is place
to take you through the 90% of banging
your head against a brick wall but
[Music]
people put a huge amount of energy into
playing games on computers so I think
projects like this can channel that
energy into solving real-world problems
and that's a way in which everyone can
contribute that really hasn't been there
before I'm Susannah litski and I'm an
administrator in Manchester and my
folding gaming name is also Suzanne
hello I'm Charlie I'm a bench technician
and in my spare time I play folding I
used to be number two in the world my
gaming tag is Charlie Falls conscience
I'm a member of the contenders it's
essentially a 3d jigsaw puzzle
you're given a protein which comprises
of a backbone in individual side chains
and by moving these around changing the
interactions your score either goes up
or down
scientists are engine working out the
three-dimensional structures of proteins
because they help understand how the
proteins carry out their jobs what they
do inside cells
the principle behind the prediction of
protein structures on a computer is that
we've known for a long time that all the
information needed to determine the
structure of a protein is in the amino
acid sequence of the protein so from
genome sequences we can translate those
into amino acid sequences using the
genetic code and now we have this amino
acid sequence turns out that the
structure that proteins fold to is
almost always the lowest energy
structure for that amino acid sequence
so the structure prediction problem then
is finding the lowest energy structure
for that amino acid sequence and the
reason it's hard is that there's so many
different possible configurations
[Music]
big advantage that human has is they can
look at a complicated thing like a big
protein sort of zoom in on the regions
that probably most need to be reworked
and we give them visual cues the regions
that are high in energy locally are red
and so they sort of stand out that the
way you need to do something here to
start with it with the protein that is
so misshapen it's ugly and it's red and
to work through that to a beautifully
streamlined structure where it's
symmetrical and things are tucked in and
nothing is hanging out and off the sides
yeah that that is sort of the goal and
that's what I like doing to sort of help
it in some ways do to just sort of be
what it should be a really good photo
player I think needs a number of skills
problem-solving is obviously one of them
I think a slightly addictive personality
a little bit of stubbornness thrown in
and a little bit of luck on top you
don't necessarily need to have a
scientific background to play you just
need to know what works and what doesn't
and you can learn that within the game
itself I'm a administrative worker in
the rehab team I'm just answering
telephones working on a bespoke computer
programs interacting with staff it's
very repetitive when I go home I become
a different person I just like to
measure myself against something and
it's given me something that my everyday
life hasn't given me it's is to just use
abilities I didn't know how hard for me
it's
a guilty pleasure and yet here I am
involved in something that has real
relevance in the scientific world it
makes you feel very proud of what you do
which is essentially a little hobby you
can imagine where you come home and
evening and you can either either stay
up all night playing Halo or you can be
designing an HIV vaccine with people all
around the world I mean which would you
be happier saying you did when you went
into work in the morning people out
there are discovering not only
alternative protein structures but new
approaches to solving the problem so
they're really doing scientific research
even though most of the players don't
really are not practicing scientists the
computers versus human paradox as it
were is ultimately we're going to fold
ourselves out of a game we're here to
provide a sort of refinement to the
folding algorithms that protein servers
use to try and do this automatically as
we get better and feedback to the Bakker
lab the automated algorithm for the
computers will get better and ultimately
we'll be left with nothing to do
you
you
[Music]
you
you
[Music]